لمناطق امنه
[موسيقى]
كما اظهر الصور المتداوله مشاهد لعمليه
دخان تتصاعد من مطار الخرطوم الاشتباكات
الدائره بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
وفي اخر تطورات اجلاء الدول لرعاياها من
السودان نشاهد مشاهدينا هذه الصور لعبور
عدد من شاحنات الاجلاء الى الاراضي
المصريه
وتشهد الحدود المصريه السودانيه استنفارا
امنيا وفقا لمراسل العربيه حيث وصلت دفعه
جديده من الحافلات التي نراها الان على
الشاشه لانهاء اجراءات لدخول الاراضي
المصريه وراس العربيه ايضا مشاهدين افاد
بانه من المنتظر وصول وعادل من حافله
الاجلاء خلال الساعات المقبله
ومع استمرار القتال في السودان بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع تواصل الحكومه
الفرنسيه عمليات اجلال رعاياها
الدبلوماسيين من السودان فرنسا قررت
دعوتها لوضع حد للقتال والعوده الى
المحادثات السياسيه بين طرفي الصراع مؤكده
انها لا تزال على اتصال وثيق بشركائها حول
تطورات الوضع في السودان
قبل ذلك وصلت اول طائره للقوات الجويه
الالمانيه الى برلين على متنها اكثر من
100 شخص تم اجلائهم من السودان ليصل عدد
الذين نقلهم الجيش الالماني الى
313 شخصا حتى الان بحسب ما ذكره مصدر
عسكري ونقلت الطائره وهي من طراز ايرباص
اي 321 نقلت هؤلاء الاشخاص من قاعده
الازرق الاردنيه التي يستخدمها الجيش
الالماني كمركز لعمليه الاجلاء الى برلين
في سياق ذاته قرار البرلمان السويدي ارسال
اربعمائه جندي الى السودان للمساعده في
اجلاء السويديين من هناك حسب ما ذكرت
وكاله الانباء السويديه ورفضت الناطقه
باسم القوات المسلحه السويديه التعليق على
موعد تنفيذ العمليه الا انها اكدت على ان
الوضع الامني في السودان خطير للغايه
ويستوجب المتابعه عن كثب بدوره اكد وزير
الدفاع السويدي بالجونسون اكد ان القوات
المسلحه عملت بجهد مكثف على هذه القضيه
ولديها مستوى عالي من الجاهزيه لاجلاء
الرعايه
في تصريحات للعربيه اكد مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي زبوريل
للعربيه اكد بان المجتمع الدولي يضغط على
المكونين العسكريين في السودان ويقوم ببدل
جهد جهد مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب وبلوغ
تسويه سياسيه
المجتمع الدولي يضغط على الطرفين ويقوم
ببذل جهود مشتركه لوقف هذه الحرب وبلوغ
تسويه سياسيه لقد كنت اتحدث مع جميع
الجيران وجميع الاصدقاء حتى مع وجود
الجنرلين اللذين يقودان القوات رساله
المجتمع الدولي واحده وقف الحرب واسكات
المدافع والبدء في الحوار والبحث عن الحل
السياسي لانه لا يوجد حل عسكري لهذه الحرب
وهذا ما نقوم به من خلال اخراج مواطنينا
لست مضطرا للشرح ما يحدث هناك تراه انت
تشاهد التلفاز لذلك يجب ان يخرج مواطن ومن
المستحيل الاستمرار في العمل كدبلوماسي
لذا فان افضل شيء تفعله معهم هو اخراجهم
وشدد مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي على ان الكتله الاوروبيه لن تسمح
بانفجار السودان لان ذلك سيؤثر على
المنطقه وسيرسل موجات من الصدمه الى محيطه
لقد كانت عمليه معقده لكنها ناجحه موظف
الاتحاد الاوروبي 21 شخصا موجودون بالفعل
في اوروبا والعديد من مواطني الاتحاد
الاوروبي خارج السودان بالفعل لا استطيع
ان اعطيك الرقم الملموسه لكن تقريبا اكثر
من الف شخص اود ان اشكر فرنسا على
مساهمتها علينا ان نواصل الضغط من اجل
تسويه سياسيه لا يمكننا ان نتحمل ان ينهار
السودان لانه سيرسل موجات صدمه في جميع
انحاء افريقيا
نور الدين نور الدين وبدايه كيف تسير
عمليه الاجلاء لرعايه الاتحاد الاوروبي من
السودان والى اي مرحله وصلت هذه الجهد
يبدو انها تسير بصفه امنه حسب ما صرح
الوزراء منهم مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
جوزيف بوريل السفير الاوروبي سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الخرطوم غادر العاصمه
السودانيه لكنه لا يزال موجودا في السودان
حيث يتابعوا من ناحيه اوضاع الرعايه
الاوروبيين الذين لم يتمكن الاوروبيون
بعده او الدول الاوروبيه من اجلائهم بعد
وهم ربما بعض المئات ولكن بالعشرات
بالاكيد ولكن ايضا السفير الاوروبي كانت
طلعها بدور سياسي نشطا خلال مرحله
الحوارات الكثيره بين القوى السودانيه بين
القوى السياسيه في السودان والقوات
المسلحه او المجموعات المسلحه الاخرى
وجوده في مكان ما في السودان ربما يترك
الامر او يجعلوا يحافظ على هذه القناه
الحيويه بالنسبه من الناحيه الدبلوماسيه
للتواصل مع اطراف النزاع حيث اكد قبل حين
وزير خارجيه فنلندا
وهو رجل يمتلك خبره كبيره في التعامل مع
النزاعات في السودان ومع النزاعات في
القرن الافريقي بشكل عام قال ان على
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يظل متواجدا وان يقوم
بدوره على الصعيد السياسي اولا لاقناع
الطرفين بوقف اطلاق النار وثانيا
للمحاوله بايجاد حل سياسي بالتعاون مع
الامم المتحده قال ايضا اذا لم يتوقف
النزاع في السودان فانه سيتسع على الدول
الاخرى وسيدفعوا بموجات هجره كبيره نحو
الدول المجاوره وما ورائها قال ان خروج
الرعايه الاجانب سيترك الفراغ لمجموعات
فاجنر وروسيا وعلى الاتحاد الاوروبي
المواصله والاحتفاظ بوجوده السياسي في
السودان رغم الظروف
ربما كان هذا التصريح المعلن شيئا قليلا
من ما يقال في هذه الساعه داخل قاعه
الاجتماع هناك طبعا هذا الحرص الشديد على
اجزاء الرعايه الاجانب وهم والعمليه
متواصله بالنسبه لوزيره الخارجيه
البلجيكيه قالت على سبيل المثال ان ثمانيه
فقط من البلجيكينا تم اجلائهم في غضون
اليومين وان 30 او ان ثلاثين بلجيكيا لا
يزالون في السودان من بين الذين تم
اجلائهم مسؤول في بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي
عن الشؤون الانسانيه وقد اصيب هذا المواطن
البلجيكي او الدبلوماسي الاوروبي الذي
يحمل الجنسيه البلجيكيه فالعمليه متواصله
ولكن اغلب اغلب السؤال التاليه نور الدين
يعني حول ما اذا رصد هناك حالات صحيه
معينه لهؤلاء الرعايه هل هناك اعتداءات هل
هناك اصابات اعداء ما حدث للبعث الفرنسيه
التي ايضا تعرض الاعتداء بحسب المعلومات
الوارده من هناك في السودان صحيح
صحيح وزيره الخارجيه البلجيكيه حاجه
الحبيب قالت الاتي قالت تم اجلاء ثمانيه
في غضون البارحه بمساعده فرنسا وهولندا
قالت ايضا من بين هؤلاء دبلوماسيون اوروبي
يحمل الجنسيه البلجيكيه مسؤول عن السياس
عن الشؤون الانسانيه اصيب في السودان
بمعنى انه اصيب قبل اياما خلال الاعتداء
الذي
استهدف البعثه بعثه الاتحاد الاوروبي في
الخرطوم لكن معلوم ايضا ان عدد من الرعايه
الاوروبيين تعرضوا لعمليات سطو او عمليات
محاوله النهب او الاعتداء لافتكاك بعض
الممتلكات مثل ما اصيب المواطن الفرنسي
امس خلال عمليات النقل نقل الرعايه داخل
الخرطوم لان هناك نقاط
وخطوط مواجهه عده لمجموعات مسلحه متفرقه
في الخرطوم
خارجه عن القانون تقوم بالاعتداءات وحاولت
في مرات عده
الاعتداء على قوافل الدبلوماسيين
والرعايه الاوروبيين هذا ما جعل
الدبلوماسيين يصفون هات العمليه بانها
معقده بان مساله التفاوض لانتقال هذه
القوافل في الميدان عمليه صعبه جدا خاصه
احيانا لا يوجد مع من يتفاوض المسؤول
الدبلوماسي او الدبلوماسي الاوروبي او
العسكري الاوروبي الذي كان يحمل ربما زي
مدنيا عمليا ايضا خارج شمال ام درمان توجد
القاعده العسكريه
وادي سيدنا القاعده العسكريه وادي سيدنا
بها مهبط للطائرات مهبط امن للطائرات هناك
رابطه العشرات من القوات الخاصه لدول
اوروبيه وهي التي اشرفت على على عمليه
اجراء الرعايه الاوروبيين
نحو
نحو القاعده العسكريه في الفرنسيه في
جيبوتي او القاعده الامريكيه في جيبوتي
ومن هناك الى قواعد اخرى ومطارات اخرى في
المنطقه مثل مطار عمان في الاردن ما اكثر
ما يخلق الاوروبيين نور الدين مما يحدث في
السودان حاليا هل القلق من الهجره غير
الشرعيه من موجات النزوح على القلق من
انتشار بؤر ارهابيه في المنطقه عطف على
الهشاشه الامنيه الحاصله حاليا
يعني هناك اولا احمد اذا سمحت لي هناك خوف
على السودانيين انفسهم من هذه الحرب التي
دمرت الى حد الان جزء من النسيج السياسي
السياسي وجزء من ما انجزته المحاولات
الحوار والحوارات السياسيه بين السودانيين
انفسهم وزير وزير الخارجيه الذي تحدث
اليوم عن ان المدنيين في السودان يعانون
الامرين وان هناك حاجه ماسه وحاجه ملحه
لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في هذه
اللحظات التي وساعات التي نتحدث فيها عن
الازمه السودانيه ولكن ايضا
الخوف هو من ان ينتشر النساء النزاع داخل
السودان لماذا لان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه طبعا لها قدراتها في المدن
والاقليم واقليم وولايات السودان ولكن
ايضا قوات الدعم السريع لها امكاناتها
العسكريه
كبيره جدا في المدن الاخرى والاقاليم
والارياف وخاصه في منطقه دارفور فاذا خرج
النزاع عن السيطره خارج الخرطوم وطال
المدن الاخرى فهنا الخوف على السودانيين
والخوف على المنطقه وهذا ما تحدث عنه
تحدثت عنه وزيره الخارجيه البلجيكيه تحدث
عنه وزير الخارجيه الفنلندي صباح صباح
اليوم وهو موضوع مشاورات مكثفه بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول المنطقه ايضا لان
الخوف من الهجرات من هجرات اللاجئين
والهجرات المكثفه نحو الساحه الافريقي
اللي هي منطقه هشه جدا على الصعيد الامني
وبالنسبه لاستقرارها وطبعا تاثيرات مباشره
ايضا على شمال افريقيا هناك خوف من ان
تتحول السودان الى ليبيا اخرى بمعنى ان
تقسم البلاد بين قوتين عسكريتين الحال كان
في الحال في ليبيا بين شمال وغرب البلاد
وهنا بين القوات المسلحه وقوات الدعم
السريع زائد ان السودان يتميز بمكوناته
طبعا القبليه ومكوناته السياسيه الاخرى
وهي هناك العديد من المجموعات المسلحه
لذلك الحاله يعني الحاجه ملحه جدا للضغط
وانتزاع وقف اطلاق النار دعني نقول باي
ثمن سياسي في هذه المرحله حتى لا تخرج
الاوضاع عن السيطره احمد
هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من لوكس كنت معنا
مراسل العربيه نور الدين
مشاهدينا من لندن ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني الطيب الزين اهلا بك سيد
الطيب معنا في هذه الساعه من التغطيه هل
من الثقه بمكان ان توصف هذه الازمه بانها
الاسوء في تاريخ السودان وهل كان ما حدث
حتى الان متوقع بنسبه اليك عطفا على ما
رشح من مؤشرات ومن معطيات في الفتره
الماضيه
بدايه ارحب بك وارحب بالمستمعين ومشاهدي
قناه العربيه فيما يتعلق بسؤالك حول
الازمه الحاليه اعتقد او يعني مؤمن قاطعا
وجازما ان هذه الازمه التي تمر بها البلاد
هي الاسوا في تاريخ السودان لكنها ليست
يعني غريبه علينا اذا عدنا الى تاريخ
بتاريخ السودانيه الوراء ثلاث عقود نجد ان
الجماعات السياسي فقط على السلطه في
السودان في 89 ومن ثم مارست خرابا وتدميرا
للدوله السودانيه في كل المؤسساتها وايضا
نشرت المفاهيم التخلف
والجهل والجهويه والعنصريه ولذلك نحن نحسب
حصاد هذه بناء السنين المره هو الدينين
المظلمه فهذا بالنسبه للسودانيين او
المتابعين للوضع السياسي فانا هي نتيجه
طبيعيه
للمالات التي اخذنا اليها
الاسلاميين في 89 والان الشعب السوداني
يدمن صح نحن الان في قمه الجبل
ولكن باراده شعبنا الذي ازاح عمر البشير
والان ايضا يقاوم بكل ما يستطيع من اجل
التخلص من بقايا دوله الاسلاميين او
الارهابيين بشكل صحيح لانه هذه المعركه هي
ليست معركه للشعب السوداني وليست معركه
الجيش السوداني وانما هي معرفه الجماعات
الظلاميه التي سقطت السلطه
هناك من يختلف معك يعني في هذا الطرح الذي
تفضلت به يعني هناك من يرى ان
تعليق هذه الازمات المتلاحقه في السودان
على
على الثلول النظام السابق او النظام
السابقيه مجرد شماعه لتعليق اسباب الفشل
في العمليه السياسيه الحاليه وان اربع
سنين كافيه منذ ثوره وحتى الان لرسم خريطه
جديده لمستقبل البلاد ما رايك
وعسى ما حدث وهذا ما حدث بالفعل انه
الشعب السوداني استطاع ان ينجز بعون
ومساعده الاشقاء في المحيط الاقليمي
بالذات الاشتقاق السعوديه والامارات وايضا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا
انجزوا يعني من خلال الرباعيه تعادل
السودانيين نحو يصلوا الى اتفاق سياتو
بالفعل هل تقدم وكان يسمى الاتفاق
الايطالي الق
وه المدني من حيث الرؤيه السياسيه
للمستقبل
وتبقى الجزء المتعلق بالشغل العسكري وهنا
تدخل الاسلاميين
وعبر فلوم الموجودين في الساحه
وادجوا الحرب في لحظه نحن الشعب السوداني
كله كان يتوقع ان تطفي
العمليه السياسيه الى سلام والى استقرار
وتفتح ابواب المستقبل او الشعب السوداني
يعبر من من الظلام الى حيث النور لكن هذه
الجماعات استبغت هذه العمليه وادخلت
البلاد في هذا
المستنقعات هي السبب فيما قالت اليها
اوضاع السودان الان كما تفضلت يعني كيف
يمكن ان تخدم الاوضاع الحاليه مصالح هذه
الجماعات
نعم الان يعني ربما يعني تتابعون يعني
العمليات التي تمت في سجل الهدى كلها
الهدف منها اخراج
يعني رؤساء هذه الجماعات يعني بدءا من عمر
البشير وحشيته الفاسده التي كانت تقطع في
السجون وكانت تنتظر المحاكمات
في البلد حتى تنفذ بجلبها
وتعيس الفوضى ولذلك نحن الان كما قلت لك
اتطلع الى
محيطنا العربي والافريقي والمجتمع الدولي
ان يطلعوا بدورهم الانسان بدورهم الاخلاقي
في مساعده الشعب السوداني التغلب على هذه
الجماعه لانه هذه الجماعه اذا ما سيطرت
على السودان ستنشر الدمار والخراب وكل دول
المنطقه لن تلعب بالاستقرار تنعود الى
سنوات الظلام سنوات القهر والاستبداد
لعلكم متابعون لما حدث في السودان خلال
عقود الماضي طيب عمليه الاجلال الرعايه
الاجانب التي تمضي على قدم الوساق حاليا
في السودان ما الذي يمكن ان نستشفه منها
على صعيد مستقبل هذه الازمه في البلاد هل
هي مؤشر في تقديرك على انتقال هذه
المواجهات الى مرحله جديده قد تكون اكثر
عنفا
انا يعني اتمنى انه كل الرعايه الموجودين
في السودان يخرجوا من السودان بسلام لكن
ايضا انا ايضا يعني اغلق على على ابناء
شعبي وعلى وطني وعلى بلادي من ما ينتظرها
من من فتره مظلمه لانه الان اذا ما خرج
الدبلوماسيين او الرعايه الدول الاخرى من
السودان فالمساله تبدا مفتوحه لهذه
الجماعات ان تمارس العبث الى مراقبه يعني
جهات تراغب الاوضاع ولذلك يعني انا اتمنى
انه على المجتمع الدولي في محيطنا العربي
والافريقي في النوم يبذلوا قصاره جهدهم
بالتقلب على هذه الجماعه وفرض يعني قطاع
جوي لفتح هذه القوه في البرهان وفنون
النظام السابق حتى يجبروهم على السلام
لانهم لا يوجد مخرج سواء الحوار سواء طا
وله طاوله الحوار يعني لا يوجد حل عسكري
في كل التجارب
الحرب العالميه الاولى الحرب العالميه
الثانيه حددوا الحروب الاقليميه كلها
انتهت الى طلب المفاوضات
ولا يعني دول المنطقه في الجوار صحفي في
هذه الفوضى
فهذه
المكان في المحيط العربي او
الدول في اوروبا وفي امريكا او في مجلس
الامن او المتحده
في وسائل الاعلام هم مصران تماما على
استمرار استمارهما في استخدام المقاربه
العسكريه لحل هذه الازمه وضروره حسم
العسكري لكن ما هي النقطه في تقديرك التي
يمكن عندها ان اقتنع الطرفان بدوره اللجوء
الى طاوله الحوار
ان الجماعه الحاليه يعني انا
واستمعت لخطابات البرهان وجماعته الدعم
السري
ع يقول ليست له المصلحه وليست له اجنده
خفيه هو يريد ان يحدث يعني انتقال
يعني السلطه للمدنين بينما البرهان
والخلفه الجماعات الاسلاميه تريد ان تبطل
هذا المسار ولذلك هي ليست في مصلحتها ان
يكون هناك ثلاث فالان الامور يعني يجب ان
تؤخذ بهذا الفهم انه
حتى تاتي الى
الحق يعني
وتستجيب يعني اذا لم يحدث تدخل واذا لم
يحدث
من المجتمع
الدولي لم يعني يستجيبوا للمصلحه الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
مشهد العسكري حتى يفرض عليهم
والواقع لانه هذه اراده الشعب السوداني
الشعب السوداني مع السلام مع الاستقرار مع
الانفتاح على بعضنا البعض
يعني هل المشكله في البرهان بذاته يعني هل
المشكله هي المشكله في مشكله في شخص بذاته
[موسيقى]
يسيروا رئيسا ولذلك هو يعمل بهذه بهذه
الاكذوبه الكبرى ماذا عن قاده الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان
لكن انا احاول اقدم توصيف للواقع كما هو
الان اذا المجتمع الدولي ما الضغط على
البرهان وعلى الجماعات التي خلفهم نستطيع
ان ننتقل من المربع الحرق الى مربع
التفاوض والسلام ومن ثم التحول المدني
الديمقراطي الذي ينشره الشعب السوداني ولا
ظللنا نناضل من اجله ثلاث عقود
الطيف يعني في زاويه اخرى يعني الهدنه
الحاليه هي الافضل نسبيا من حيث الالتزام
بها من قبل الطرفين مقارنه بالهدن السابقه
التي انهارت منذ ساعاتها الاول هل يعود
ذلك الى حرص الطرفين على اجلاء الرعايه
الاجانب دون تعقيدات من السودان ام ان
هناك اسباب اخرى في تقديرك
انا لا يعني هل هم الفين هاي الاهداف اذا
كان هناك اهداف في اهداف الفوضى زي ما قلت
لكم وعدم الاستقرار وليس يعني يعني هناك
يعني مصلحه للشعب السوداني او حتى للطرف
الاخر انه يعني يجعل من الرهاين قضيه او
يجعل منهم يعني
سواتر او يعني ايا كان لا لكن الجماعه
الاسلاميه او الجماعه المتطرفه هي تستخدم
تستخدم تستخدم هذا
الامر بمصلحتها وحتى الاحتفاءات التي حصلت
خلال الايام الماضيه ضد ضد الرعايه الاجت
كان الهدف منها يعني خلق حاله من الرعب
وتهديد وسلامه الرعايه الطيب لو سمحت لو
فهمت سؤالي يعني اتحدث عن الهدنه الحاليه
لماذا نجحت دون عن بقيه الهدن السابقه
لم تنجح في الواقع لكن شعروا بان الله
شعرك الاطراف المعنيه كلها بان مصلحتها في
انها تقدم صوره للمجتمع الدولي بانها يعني
تتوائم وتحترم
هكذا ولكن في كل الاحوال يعني هذه يعني
مجرد يعني عمليه عقد خدع لكن الواقع يقول
انه هذه الجماعات لن تحافظ على اذا لم
تحافظ على الامن السودان السوداني لم
تحافظ على امن الاجانب والسودان مقبل على
مرحله مظلمه انا اتمنى وهذا ما يهمني صحيح
انا اتمنى الاجانب يخرج من السودان لكن
اهمني
مصير البلاد مصير الشعب السود
الوطن على الشعب السوداني ان يتحد ان يوجد
هذه المؤامره والمجتمع الدولي عليها ان
يساعد الشعب السوداني حتى يحتوي هذه
الازمه بدلا اني يعني تتوسع وتبقى يعني
يعني
لا نستطيع ان نسيطر عليها فاتمنى من الشعب
السوداني ان يقف وقفه رجل واحد حتى نقضي
على هذه المؤامره ونفتح ابواب الامل وامام
المستقبل او الشعب السوداني طيب اود ان
سؤالك سؤالا اخيرا ربما على الوضع
الميداني في البلاد الحضور الذي يشكل قائد
الدعم السريع على المستوى الاعلامي او حتى
على مستوى الاتصالات مع اطراف دوليه اضافه
لتحركه بحريه ايضا هل هي شواهد على ان
الرجل ما زال قادرا على فرض نفسه على
المشهد وان الكلمه ليست هذا الجيش فقط كما
يروج
نعم نعم يعني الان في الواقع انه قوات
الدعم السريع هي تصف
ولم يحدث من جانو هذه
القوات او سمعنا او يعني اي جهات دعت او
يعني عبرت عن طريقها من هذه القوات
لانه هذه القوات يعني تم الغدر بها لانها
وقفت الى جانب تحول الديمق هذه الحقيقه
هؤلاء الناس يعني يريدون ان يخلفوا الفوضى
بمجرد ان دخلوا العاصمه كسر
السجود الفوضى وحاولوا ان يلبسوا هذه
الافعال المجرمه في قوات الدعم بين قوات
الدعم السريع وكل المواقع التي تسيطر لم
تعتدي على المواطنين لم تخرب المصالح
العامه للبلد وانما حافظت قدره ما استطعت
والله نستطيع يعني لما كان ان يغير
المعادله ويلقي وجود هذه القوات موجوده
كويس والعمليه السياسيه انجلس الشعب
السوداني بيبدا
المطلوب الان هو الموارطه الضغط على
البرهان وعلى الجماعه الانقلابيه
والجماعات الاسلاميه التي تحاول ان تعيش
الفوضى في البلاد حتى يعني يعني السودان
يستقر ويكون دوله قادره
بالاطلاع في وظيفتها تجاه شعبها واتجاهها
وطنها واتجاه مجتمعها في محيطها الاقليمي
والدولي
هذا قدر شكرا لك من لندن كنت معنا الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني الطيب الزين شكرا جزيلا
لك
مشاهدينا نشرت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
صوره لوزير الخارجي عن طريق وهو يراقب
عمليه اجلاء الموظفين واسرهم من السفاره
واشنطن في الخرطوم واجلت القوات المسلحه
للولايات المتحده وبريطانيا موظف
سفارتيهما من السودان بينما سارع الدول
الاخرى لايصال مواطنيها الى بر الامان مع
اندلاع القتال بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في العاصمه
كما قالت مديره الوكاله الامريكيه للتنميه
الدوريه سامانثا باور ان الوكاله نشرت
فريقا من خبراء التعامل مع الكوارث من اجل
تنسيق المساعدات الانسانيه للسودان في ظل
الاستنبار القتال هناك وقالت باور في بيان
ان الفريق سيعمل من كينيا في المرحله
الاولى واضافت ان الخبراء سيعملون مع
المجتمع الدولي والشركاء لتحديد
الاحتياجات ذات الاولويه وتقديم مساعدات
الانسانيه بامان واوضحت مديره الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه ان الولايات المتحده
تحشد الجهود لزياده المساعدات للشعب
السوداني المحاصر بين الجانبين المتحاربين
مذكره بمعاناتهم في ظل نقص الامدادات
الغذائيه والادويه وانقطاع التيار
الكهربائي في سياق اخر مشاهدينا شددت باور
على ان هذا القتال الذي يدور حاليا بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع تسبب
في حصد ارواح المئات وقضى مره اخرى على
تطلعات ديمقراطيه للشعب السوداني حسب
قولها ثم جددت دعوتها لجانبين المتحاربين
لالتزام بخدمه من اجل تسهيل وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه للسودان في امان ودون
عوائق
اعلنا الرائد حسين هدايا عمر عيسى من قوات
الدعم السريع ومجموعته المكونه من 125
عربه بكامل العتاد الى الجيش السوداني
وذلك استجابه لقرار القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه
انا الرايت حسين هدايه عمر العيساوي تابع
لقوات الدعم السرير والان انضميت اختي
الان انضميت للقوات المسلحه
باغرار
الاغرار القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
ومعايميه 125 فرد وخمسه وعشرين عربيه
وبناشد اخواني في الدعم في الدعم السريع
ينضموا للقوات المسلحه لحقنا للدماء
ولحقنا للدماء وانا بناشد اخواني كلهم في
الدعم السريع والجيش الماضي انضموا كلهم
ينضموا في اقرب ويحضر القوات المسلحه وين
احنا متكيفين ذات القرار السيد الغايب
لارجاع قوات القوات الحرس الحدود للقوات
المسلحه
من القاهره ينضموا لنا الباحث في مركز
الاهرام الدراسه السياسيه والاستراتيجيه
صلاح خليل صلاح معنا في هذه التغطيه بدايه
عمليه استهداف البحث الدبلوماسيه
والاجنبيه سرعت بشكل او باخر من عمليه
اجراء هؤلاء الرعايه من السودان هل ياتي
هذا الاستهداف او يعود لحاله
الهشاشه الامنيه والفوضى القائمه حاليا في
البلاد ام ان هناك اسباب اخرى في تقديرك
المجتمع الدولي نعم هنالك قلق من المجتمع
الدولي للرايه الموجوده في السودان في ظل
الاشتباكات المستمره
للاسبوع الثاني
وايضا هنالك هي اشاره واضحه بان
القلق من سحب الرائع او المغادره الرعايه
للخرطوم ياتي ضمن ان ليس هنالك افقا
لعمليه انهاء هذا الصراع الذي يدخل
الاسبوع الثاني
بالرغم من ان هنالك مؤشرات ودلالات تشير
بان الاسبوع الثاني من الصراع التحولت فيه
ميزان القوه
الاصطلاح الجيش السوداني لذلك راينا ان
الهدنه التي تمت
العقيده ربما لم تقل الاشتباكات على محور
محاور عديده باستثناء بعض جيوب المقاومه
الموجوده قريبه من المطار او القياده
العامه وايضا الجيوب المقاومه لاخوات
الدعم الموجوده على مناطق متطرفه في احياء
من الخرطوم بحري وايضا في احياء في غرب ام
درمان او في مدينه ام درمان في احياء
نائيه وبعيده
ايضا القلق اياتي نتيجه لان الاسبوع
الثاني يشير ايضا انه هنالك لا امل لاي
تفاور التفاوض بين طرفي الصراع بسبب ما
حققته الجيش السوداني مع قهوه الجيش
السوداني في استقبال الاستراتيجيه ذا
استراتيجيه قويه ذات النفس اعتمدت
ضبط النفس اعتمدت على ان
عقليه المؤسسه العسكريه في محاربه قوات
الدعم السليم في حرب الشوارع بل مقابل
قوات الدعم السريع في ظل الهدنه الثالثه
تراجعت كثير نسبه لان العتاده والمعن
الغذائيه التي كانت تستخدمها اصبحت في
اتنفس وبالتالي هي اصبحت تعاني انها سوف
تفقد الاتاده العسكريه وايضا سوف تفقد
الاتهاد الغذائي التي كانت هي تتوقع ان لا
تطول هذه الازمه او ربما كانت تمتدات
لاسبوع
حتى اللحظه رغم هذه الضربات الموجه التي
تلقتها من الجيش الى لم يعد ذلك في تقديرك
وهل تتوقع ان هذه القوات تتلقى فعلا دعبا
خارجيا كما افاد بذلك مسؤولون في الجيش
السوداني
نعم قوات الدعم السرير لا زالت تقاتل في
بعض المناطق وده شيء طبيعي جدا لانها هي
انسحبت من الكثير من المناطق التي كانت
تتمركز فيها فاصبحت ايضا تستخدم اسلوب
التكتيك او اسلوب التي كانت تتبعه في
عمليه السطو الى المحلات التجاريه وداني
هنا عشير بعيدا بعيدا ما يتناوله طرفي
الصراع حول الدعم السريع هنالك مجموعه
كثير من السودانيين كانوا يتصورون من
شرفات منازل لهم وايضا من الاماكن التي
كانت تتواجد فيها الدعم السريع انها اصبحت
ترتكب يعني بعض التجاوزات في في حق
الممتلكات العامه او حتى الممتلكات الخاصه
وراينا كثير يعني بعيدا ان ما يقال من
طرفي الصراع
ويضعان ان هنالك هذه هي الجماعات
الاسلاميه او او ذلك لن ايضا نشير الى
نقطه مهمه جدا كثير من
الطرفي استخدمانها وهي
موجود الجامعات الاسلاميه السياسي وهي
التي قامت بالتفريق السجون هذه هي طبعا
غير حقيقيه احنا راينا مجموعه من السجناء
ايضا مجموعه من الذين خرجوا من السجون
وقالوا نحن سوف نسلم انفسنا متى ستتم
الامن في البلاد وبالتالي انه اشعر بوضوح
بان قوات الدعم التي من قامت
السجون وايضا قامت باغتيال بعض الضباط
والشروطيه اللي كانت موجوده
كانت هي للتامين السجن فقط وبالتالي كانت
نسبه السيارات التي دخلت السجون وانا
استمعت الى شريط فيديو من احد المجندين في
قوات الشرطه السودانيه اشار في وضوح انهم
اضطروا انه دخلوا الى المساجين ان يدوهم
ملابس القوه التي حجمت على سيدنا الهدى
قرض ام درمان ايضا
في ظل هذه الفوضى في السجون يعني هل نت
وقع ايضا
افراجا عن
رموز النظام السابق بما فيه من الرئيس
السابق البشير
لا اتخذ ذلك لان المؤسسه العسكريه كانت
تتحسب
لمثل هذه
الازمه وايضا تحفظت رموز السياسي في مناطق
مختلفه بعيدا ما يشاء انها هي في سجن كوبر
وفي سجن كوبر كما تعلم تم اقتحام من قوات
الدعم السليم فبالتالي لم يجد قيادات
الاسلام السياسي وهي كانت فكره اقتحام
السجون من قبل قوات الدعم السريع هي في
ارشاد رسائل الى السودانيين بان
هذه من اطلق من قام باقتحام السجون هم
فضول النظام السابق ولكن في الواقع هذه هي
شماعه تستخدم من قبل ما يدعمون الدعم
السريع وايضا كانت تستخدم من قبل القوه
السياسيه التي هي دفعت
الدفات ودعمت انه قوات الدعم السريع ان
تقوم بهذه المعو الانقلابيه نقطه اخرى
مهمه جدا ايضا
الاستراتيجيه التي اتبعت من المؤسسه
العسكريه وايضا من الدعم السريع كانت تدل
بان الاقليه التي سائده لقوات الدعم
السريع بقاصه في ظل وجود هيئه العمليات
هيئه العمليات هي جزء من جهاز المخابرات
الان في السودان هي قامت كانت في زمن
الاسلام السياسي او زمن البشير كانت هي
التي تشرف على قوات الدعم من تدريب وايضا
من تجهيزات عسكريه فهي كانت تعرف رقما
القوه والضعف لدى القوات الدعم السريع
لذلك اشتراك
هيئه العمليات ساهم بدور كبير جدا في
اضعاف القوات الدعم السريع وايضا انهاكها
في حرب الشوارع وايضا الساحل بدرجه كبيره
جدا
سلاح الطيران الجو السوداني من خلال
الخروج والحروب من داخل الخرطوم بعد ان ان
فشلت المحاوله فتم قصفهم اذا نحن نتكلم عن
معادله في الاسبوع الثاني ليس فيها اي
بادره لعمليه حوار سياسي ليس فيها بادره
ان تكون هنالك تسويه سياسيه يكون فيها
قائد الدعم السريع في داخل المعادله
السياسيه السودانيه طيب الصراع اليوم يدور
حول مواقع حيويه واستراتيجيه انتشرت اليها
في بدايه حياتك ايضا هذه المواقع
الاستراتيجيه ان اتحدث عن القصه الجمهوري
عن بيت الضيافه عن القياده العامه عن
المطار وجود هذه المناطق الحيويه في مناطق
مهوله بالسكان هل يعد سيد صلاح امرا
طبيعيا ومقبولا في الداخل السوداني لانه
من الواضح انه يعد من عوامل ارتفاع فاتوره
سقوط الضحايا المدنيين في هذه الازمه
نعم لذلك لهذه لهذه الظروف استخدمت
استخدمت الجيش السوداني تكتيك مختلف
التفاديا من وقوع عديد من الضحايا في ظل
وجود قوات الدعم هذه
وايضا هي نقطه دائن الى نقطه
وجود
قوات الدعم السريع في هذه المنطقه لان كان
قائد قوات الدعم السريع يعمل بجهد كبير
جدا في عمليه تفكيك هيئه العمليات
فبالتالي
تفكيك هيئه العمليات ساهم بجزء كبير ان
تكون تلك المغاره التي كانت هي احدى
مرتكزات هيئه العمليات اصبحت من خلال لجنه
التمكين
التسليمها الى قوات الدعم السليم ايضا
نقطه اخرى مهمه الاشتباكات التي تدور داخل
المطار و حول المطار هي ايضا تسببت فيها
لجنه تفكيك النظام السابق بينما قامت
بتسليم حزب المؤتمر الوطني المنحل الى
قوات الدعم السريع وهو طبعا كما تعلم جيدا
قرب به واقربه اللصيق من مطار الخرطوم هذه
الاسباب التي جاءت لا زالت هنالك اشتباكات
تدور في هذه المنطقه بالكثافه السودانيه
ولكن اعتقد انه المؤسسه العسك السودان
هتمتلك من القدره تمتلك من الاستراتيجيات
تمتلك من الرؤيه تمتلك من التفكير الانيق
في كيفيه المحاربه او كيفيه الدخول في
اشتباكات في هذه المناطق من اجل ان لا
يكون هنالك ضرر كبير على المدنيين
السودانيين احداث اليوم في السودان هل
ستفرض واقعا جديدا على مساله تعدد الجيوش
والحركه المسلحه في العاصمه الخرطوم
والبقيه المدن الكبرى
مع الاخ في الاعتبار ان هذا كان من ضمن
المطالب التي طالب بها يطالب بها شارع
السوداني في السنوات الماضيه
نعم هي في الفكره ليست هي مطالبه الشارع
السوداني بل هي مطالب بعض القوى السياسيه
لذلك هنالك بعض القوه السياسيه طالبت
بوجود يعني الدعم السريع ولكن الفكره وجود
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم هي ليست كانت
فكره القوه السياسيه الموجوده
اخراج هذه المجموعات المسلحه خارج العاصمه
والاكتفاء بالجيش السوداني فقط كمؤسسه
شرعيه في البلاد
نعم هو كان هذا هذا كان هذا النهدي متبع
انه وجود الاخوات الدعم الصديق خارج
الخرطوم كان نهدي متبع جدا ولكن عندما
انفجرت مظاهرات
نظام الاسلام السياسي في السودان
وقتها استخدم البشير قوات الدعم وسمعه لها
بالدخول في السودان او دخول في العاصمه
وانا اشرت في كتابات سابقه وايضا في
لقاءات سابقه انه دخول القوات الدعم
السريع الى الخرطوم في 2013 ربما ترتكت
مجزره في المستقبل وهذا هو ما حدث النقطه
الاخر النقطه الاخرى كانت ايضا هنالك
مخاوف من الرئيس البشير بان المؤسسه
العسكريه اللي فيها بعض القيادات اصبحت
تفكر في عمليه مشروع اصلاح ضد البشير فذلك
البشير فيعني فكره وجود قوات الدعم السرير
في الخرطوم كانت فكره ان يضع حدا للذين
يحاولون التخور على السلطه او حتى عمليه
الذين كانوا يفكرون على الانقلاب في
السلطه هذه هي مجمل الاسباب التي دفعت
نظام الاسلام السياسي السابق في الخرطوم
ان يسمح لدخول قوات كبيره جدا من الدعم
السريع الخرطوم وايضا ليس فقط السماح لها
ايضا السماح لها من خلال التصويت داخل
البرلمان ان تجاس لها ميزانيه ضخمه جدا
جدا فبالتالي اذا احنا نتكلم عن ميليشيات
كانت جزء من نظام الاسلام السياسي ايضا ان
اضيف نقطه اخرى رايت رايت كل الناس تتحدث
عن عمليه التحول الديمقراطي وعمليه تسليم
السلطه المدني من طرف اليسرى
في ذلك عندما ان نتحدث ان الديمقراطيه
الديمقراطيه كما معلوم هي نظام سياسي اذا
الديمقراطيه تريد وطني تطبق فيه هذه
الانظمه اذا لم يكن هنالك وطن الشخصي فلا
يمكن ان تكون هنالك عمليات التحول
الديمقراطي او تسليم السلطه للمدنيين
الوطن فوق كل شيء فبالتالي الديمقراطيه لا
تطبق في الهواء او لا تطبق في البر يعني
وفي الجو يعني فبالتالي يعني المعادله
السياسيه القادمه في السودان سوف تفرض
السديده ربما كثيرين يصطدمون من المعادله
السياسيه التي سوف تكون في بعض انتهاء
الازمه الحاليه ربما تفرط واقع جديده
مغاير لوجود قوه سياسيه لان القوه
السياسيه الموجوده حاليا هي ربما تسببت
بنسبه كبيره عندما
احتمد او عندما يعني تخيل لها ان تقوم
بدعم رائد قوات الدعم السريع ان يخش في
مواجهه مع مؤسسه
اسمح لي فقط يعتبر قد دقيقه واحده اريد ان
اسالك عن زاويه اخرى في هذا الملف يعني
مدى قلقا لتشعر به مصر وانت متواجد في مصر
حاليا ومدير مركز الاهرام الدراسات او
واحد في هذا المركز ما مدى قلق لتشعر به
مصر اذا ما يحدث في السودان وفي اي اتجاه
تتحرك مصر مستقبلا وفق ما المعطيات
الحاليه في السودان
تفضلت انا دقيقه واحده
القاهره اتخذت موقفا ايجابيا من الازمه
بانها هي لا تتدخل في الشان السوداني
وايضا هي لا ليس لديها ان تكون طرفا على
الاخر لذلك منذ بدايه الازمه القاهره كانت
لجلسه طارئه للمندوبين الداعمين لجامعه
الدول العربيه لمناقشه الازمه في السودان
القاهره نعم تقف في موقف يدي لانها لا
تريد ان تتدخل في الازمه الداخليه
السودانيه لانه ربما يعقد المشهد اكثر
وايضا
طالبه العديد من الدول انه هذا الازمه في
السودان ازمه شانه داخلي ويجب ان تتم في
اطار في ظل الاطار الداخلي السوداني بعيدا
عن ان المحاور الاقليميه او الدوليه لذلك
كانت هذه هي وجهه نظر القاهره في الازمه
منذ بدايتها
شكرا لك من القاهر كنت معنا الباحث في
مركز الاهرام للدراستات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه صلاح خليل تحياتي السيد
صلاح
اعلنت في الخارجيه صينيه انها ارسلت قوه
مهمات للسودان واجلت بل اجلت مجموعه من
الموظفين والمواطنين بامان الى احدى دول
الجوار وذكرت المتحدثه باسم الخارج
الصينيه تتابع تطورات في السودان عن كثب
وتؤيد جهود التهدئه ووقف اطلاق النار
[موسيقى]
هذا هو رسبه كاميرا العربيه مشاهد اي لحظه
وصول مواطنين اردنيين وراعي دول عربيه الى
مطار ماركا في العاصمه الاردنيه عمان
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله نوعا ما ممتازه يعني الشباب ما
شاء الله ما قصروا طوالي وصلنا المطار على
طول عملوا لنا الدخول وطلعنا على الطياره
والحمد لله امورنا تمام احنا بالنسبه لنا
كان القصف جنبنا يعني كويس حتى شغلنا صار
في نهب صار في سرقه الشوارع الجثث يعني
شفت بعينك جثث
تقعد ثلاث اربع ايام ما شالوها منا الخير
لاخواننا في الخرطوم يعني والوضع كارثي
وماساوي وفي نقص في المواد الغذائيه
والنقص في الوسائل النقل والكهرباء كان
القصف من كل محل والضرب من كل محل الواحد
كان في محل يعني بالمره
طالعه من البيوت صعبه
المشتريات المواد التموينيه كلها الاشياء
هاي صعبه كانت
الجثث هذه
الخرطوم تحديدا في شارع المطار في شارع
عبيد ختم في شارع الستين هذه ابرز اسماء
الشوارع التي
يوجد فيها احداث معارك حقيقيه الرصاص كان
ياتي من فوق رؤوسنا دائما
كنا كثيرا يعني لا نستطيع ان نرجع الى
بيوتنا نضطر الى ان نجلس عند اخرين ونعيد
التفكير مشاهدينا بالاتهامات المتبادله
بين قائد الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح ابو
برهان وقائد قوات الدعم السري محمد حمدانو
المعروف بحميتي فخلا لقائهما غير المباشر
عبر العربيه اتهم كل طرف الاخر لبدء الحرب
وخرق الهدنه والهجوم على منازل السكان
والبعثات الاجنبيه نتابع
البرهان وحماتي جنرالاني جنح الى الحرب
بعد ان كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادناه من
توقيع اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان
وحميدتي على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر
بينهما في مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب
وتم الهجوم علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات
المتمرده
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف كل المطارات تحته على مطار
الخرطوم في مطار نياله في اشكاليه نعم
هنالك وج
ود لوزيره جدا من هذه القوات
وسط الاحسياء
المهندسين والراجمال
اين يوجد البرهان وحميتي انا موجود
المسلحه ومبارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي
وهذا شرفي لن اخرج الا محمولا على نعش
الخرطوم
الشوارع موجود في الكلي
من خلق الهدنه اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا ما في
الهدنه حتى ابتدعت لان
القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الاحياء
السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام
تم الهجوم علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات
المتمرده طبعا نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد
ان نخرج نخرج الى خارج دائره الدفاع
البرهان واتفقوا رايت عشان ممكن
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
اخرجت المواطنين في المنازل اخرجت اخلت
المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
لن تعلم
في هذه الحرب
هذه الحرب ليس فيها كاسد
مدينه الاوبيض الان امنه سالمه هانئه
مطمئنه ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح الاسواق
ومزاوله اعمالهم من صباح الغد
[تصفيق]
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمئنه
طالبت منظمه الصحه العالميه بعدم استهداف
المرافق الصحيه والعاملين والمرضى في
السودان بعدما وافقت المنظمه عده هجمات
مميته استهدفت المؤسسات الصحيه ويعاني
القطاع الطبي في السودان من اوضاع صعبه
زادها النزاع الدائر حاليا سوءا
كما العاده في كل النزاعات والصراعات
المدنيون هم الضحيه الاكبر لها وهذا وضع
السوداني اليوم جثث ملقاه في الشوارع وما
من جهه تتمكن من نقلها لمثواها الاخير مع
تضارب الاحصاءات حول عدد القتلى بين
الجهات المحليه والدوليه فترات هدنه
المتقطعه لم توفر ممرات امنه لتخفيف وطئه
النزاع وتاثيرها على المواطن السوداني
مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بالامم المتحده رصد
مقتل 413 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الحادي والعشرين
من ابريل الجاري بحسب التقرير سجلت
الخرطوم اعلى عدد من القتلى ب122 تلتا
ولايه شمال كردفان بخمسه وتسعين قتيلا ثم
ولايه شمال دارفور بواحد وستين قتيلا في
عدد المرشح للزياده كل
الانسانيه العامله في السودان اللي هي
ابرز عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف
المتنازعه من جانبها اعلنت نقابه الاطباء
ان 72% من المستشفيات القريبه من مناطق
الاشتباك توقفت عن الخدمه من اصل 79
مستشفى اساسيا في العاصمه والولايات من
المجموع الكلي للمستشفيات بقي اثنتان
وعشرون مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل او جزئي
لكنها تبقى مهدده بالاغلاق نتيجه نقص
الكوادر والامدادات الطبيه وانقطاع الماء
والكهرباء كما ان عده مناطق يكثر فيها
الجرحى لا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه الوصول
اليها بيان نقابه الاطباء اضاف ان اربعه
مستشفيات في مدينه الاوبيض تعرضت للقصف ما
يرفع العدد الكلي للمستشفيات التي قصفت
الى 13 مستشفى
اليها تسعه عشر مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء
القصري كما تعرضت ست مركبات اسعاف
للاعتداء من قبل قوات عسكريه بينما لم يتم
السماح لعدد من سيارات الاسعاف بالمرور
لنقل المرضى وايصال المعونات حسب ما قالت
نقابه اطباء السودان من جانبه طالب الهلال
الاحمر بتحييد المنشات الطبيه عن العمليات
القتاليه لتجنب الانهيار الكامل للقطاع
الصحي في السودان حسن جوليد العربيه
يعني شبه كل سكان يعني
احنا لنا ثمانيه ايام بالليله في بدايه
الاحداث لم يعني لا تماما ولا يوجد عندنا
كهرباء كنا في
[موسيقى]
قوم
ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
تغطيه الحيه للاحداث في السودان مستمره
لكن نتوقفوا مع بعض الاخبار في ملفات اخرى
اعلن وزير الدفاع التركي
ورؤساء استخبارات تركيا وروسيا وسوريا
وايران غدا الثلاثاء في موسكو حيث سيتم
تخصيص الاجتماع لاعاده بناء العلاقات بين
تركيا وسوريا وبحث تطورات في الشمال
السوري بحسب وكاله الاناضول هذا وصدفه
اجتماعا لوزير الدفاع السوري والتركي في
ديسمبر من العام الماضي
عفوا
التقارب بين الاطراف الثلاثه
وانفجرت اخرى من تلقاء نفسها مشيرا الى
عدم وقوع اي اضرار تجدر الاشاره مشاهدينا
الى ان استيب هي القاعده الرئيسيه لاسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي وفي الاشي الاخيره
جرت عده محاوله لمهاجمتها بمسيرات جويه
ومائيه
يتوجه رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه يون سكيو الى
واشنطن في زياره تستغرق سته ايام حيث يعزز
الحلفاء التعاون العسكريه بشان برنامج
الاسلحه النوويه الموسعه لكوريا الشماليه
كما سيبحث الطرفان سبوره تعزيز العلاقات
بين البلدين وايضا مناقشه التطورات
الحاصله بخصوص كوريا الشماليه والحرب على
اوكرانيا
كشفت مراجعه عسكريه بل مراجعه العسكريه ان
الحكومه الاستراليه تحتاج لانفاق المزيد
من الاموال على الدفاع في الوقت الذي يشكل
الوجود العسكري الصيني تحديا الامن
الاقليمي المراجعه اوصت ايضا بزياده
الانفاق على تصنيع الذخائر وتطوير قدره
قوات الدفاع الاستراليه على ضرب اهداف
بعيده المدى بدوره صرح رئيس الوزراء
استرالي انطوني البونيز ان حكومته قامت
باجراء المراجعه لتقييم ما اذا كانت
استراليا تمتلك القدرات الدفاعيه الضروريه
وسط البيئه الاستراتيجيه الحاليه
والان مشاهدينا نعود الى استكمال تغطيه
احدث السودان مع الزميل نادي الخماش متابع
طيبه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات